how's it going bros my name is what
verify and welcome to cry affair with
cry himself that sounds really awesome
it's where policemen I like it sounded
like we are policemen well I have it
sounded like you were like coughing to
death when you were doing a job I figure
I'm not used to thank you okay
I'm the same thing alright so more cry
of fear pretty much and we have to go on
this creepy thing there and I think cry
said who saw here yeah alright I'm
coming over here cry well something
really cool yeah their bed show show me
please oh okay
oh yeah oh we have flashlights cool
those lows hey I'll go to the left no
wait you go three nights head don't we
both go through that Hey
that's right again crying oh so this is
actually like official land a fish it
was probably like Swedish police
officers that's how we draw wood so
there's not is okay they're rude people
sir are they doing here anyway I don't
know I like I like the sound of our
crawling hey you want to thank that one
oh I can do this what do you do oh wait
I have a stick it's okay Haga takes my
stick makes tell the sun's an
interesting how the heck did you miss
him
is it delay it's actually a very large
delay sir
okay Holly - Holly Gemma's got a delay
but
okay I don't think the gun is so
inefficient it's really addressed uh oh
cool
we're done crawling hey I'm glad this is
a Hanson
you should got it you bet it is show
like oh god ow I had to translate shut
show respect I guess always a bathing
structures this is there's a not allowed
in patients what I don't know that's a
mess key whatever I just got the other
that you're not supposed to use credit
cards here it says no visa your boy
it says no visa I think we're oh I
thought it said Oh FIFA know that that's
a showing speech oh you want to go
bowling
but uh no Facebook I don't have a good
smack him try do some bags in Kevin
that's right don't
why doesn't he die I'm gonna die cry I
died hope you're happy
why cry ah you're fine now
you lie oh you can I'm pumping undress
me I mean why me dude you're [ __ ]
what are you doing with my dead body
show some respect oh I'm good I'm good
alright now we can finally both together
alright you want to go first okay but
this is the same Matt or it's supposed
to be the same life I guess so I like
how we wasted all our ammo I don't know
about you I don't have any hammer I
don't have any either
Oh perfect I think yeah and and you
might want to go first
maybe I can do this wha oh those little
[ __ ] I hate them
I'll smack your butt for you okay thank
you big man make a run and I'll smack
her back why me her butt is deadly man
oh no don't die on me crying oh hey um
don't don't die just keep breathing
wait I'm uh I'm okay just chilling I'll
just bang therefore move away this I
think you're gonna die right come on man
okay I got you awesome alright
that was cool I think so too uh this is
uh we needed more training before we two
undertook this mission no it's okay we
guys you should pick up don't you have a
stick oh I have a serene don't you why
do you want to cry
I want this are you you can't have it
sorry Wow see how this ha ha um I'm
kidding
I'll give you oh I'll give you the next
thing after this one I promise
nice
the doors are sealed shut well at least
we got a bit of a battle and other
things I mean we just got and we already
killed several individuals I think we're
gonna follow the book very really oh
yeah right there oh I'm bleeding out of
my butt all right come pistol uh whoa
naked girl ah you gotta shoot him in
your titty it's the weak point for
massive damage exactly but I try to bed
but they really do much I guess down
here and then we go outside I think it's
another an accident oh no this is like
the mo Oh give that ah I'm kidding you
can have the serene you should have this
I mean actually there the door won't
budge Ville at least we got some serene
alright hey how do you say night I got
somebody comment saying I don't fit
syringe ah syringe msn learn more
English words yay
I actually totally had other weapons I
just totally forgot how to use moment or
in this kid oh yeah alright you have the
stick too right I have the stick
alright cool I'm ready for Victor why
are we going oh ok don't really sorry
you shouldn't follow me it's really a
bad idea alright here we go
we're going towards home yeah yeah I
guess that would make sense
if you're following the story or
whatever
but we're cops are we like investigating
like crimes or something no oh no
there's the bird guy what try it save me
thank you that's hot
all right uh you go first okay hello
George
judge God so George out there we're
clear yeah oh hey got some ammo for a
shotgun and some syringes this one says
I wanna be me sir I don't even know
where you went oh there yeah whoa whoa
whoa what is going on what is going on
here Christ
hold me whoa this guy's over there ah
[ __ ] in fine hide I got dogs up yeah I'm
dry
right I stick a tag charge
no it's Alice [ __ ] stick there we go
ah yeah then why why I can't have it too
odd because the game I'm recording you
but oh wait I just have them all in
balance silly me
I literally couldn't hear a thing you're
saying I okay but I think whoa
birdie-birdie
Oh crying I dropped it yeah
how's happening living I think I'll
stick to my steak yeah yeah Oh strange
go okay so when you pick up all the
things Simon me all right I guess so
because we just got it salted by Simon
2.0 got an assignment to buy on whoa
that was a birdie another one yeah this
like randomly shed it's bad gangbang why
I died why do I can't die don't like you
know I know I I forgot you can dodge in
this game I just stand there in thanking
you uh you're not playing World of
Warcraft anymore okay all right that's
my box Amma all right let's get Simon to
phone oh I don't want to play Simon 2.0
scary I know it's very long - hmm maybe
upstairs
hey I'm Pierre stop are you familiar but
it's like a sweetie
whoa where is he tt hi night dog cried
cat that it really started for house
come on you can do it ready
oh now before more firepower of sorts
exactly I can't worry something well
here we are again where are you crying
um hey currently back I got your back
I thought of rinsing yes sir
yeah but I really think upstairs is the
way to go but the question is are we
ready or not ready or not here I crack
neck from you
Jerri okay this is a learning day today
what stop pushing man you go oh yeah all
right easy now try using that take the
left there yes he's coming I don't like
this shut up
it's standing there in the face okay
you know well done yes all right I need
it right it's okay you got the stick
yeah well you take that one that's right
crying OH
I've been Mike how is he hiding me oh
it's pretty MLG double-shot us the
freaking arm oh yeah sorry Thomas come
here right maybe aah oh my god
where did he come from guys ready got
round all right Simon Cebuano suicide
work
look at my outcry they back in my ass
wonderful let it be alive anymore
heck
coming from I don't
dude it good no cry nothing I can do go
deer grazing is I don't like that I
don't want to be alone
I'm running but I think we can call it
the net so they're actually I'm friggin
shaking a didn't that was terrified it's
really about isn't it yeah it's great
when it's going on turn that down all
right but anyway like a pigeon enjoy
just gotta come birthday don't forget to
check out this christ channel i'll leave
an inscription and that's pretty much it
jeremiah activate
I'll get here